el río nilo se ha desbordado y ha
inundado sus alrededores a excepción de
la punta de la pirámide de giza se ha
enviado una expedición para descubrir la
altura que alcanzó el agua las personas
midieron el borde de la pirámide que
quedó fuera del agua y encontraron que
mide 72 metros de largo ellos saben que
la longitud total del borde es de 180
metros también saben que la altura
vertical de la pirámide es de 139 metros
cual es la altura del agua por encima
del nivel del suelo el nivel del suelo
queda más o menos por acá en la base de
la pirámide redondea el resultado a dos
lugares decimales bueno vamos a llamar
la altura que nos interesa esta de acá
vamos a llamarla h y vamos a observar
estas anotaciones de aquí
exponen que este ángulo entre el borde
de la pirámide y la altura del agua se
llama t
este ángulo del borde de la pirámide con
la base forman un ángulo de 90 m
este es un ángulo recto de 90 grados y
este ángulo 90 - theta es el complemento
de teta y usando toda esta información
podemos encontrar que este ángulo de
aquí arriba ese de acá también este está
si esto les resulta extraño
vamos a aclarar tenemos aquí un
triángulo rectángulo más o menos así sus
ángulos son uno de 90 grados un ángulo
recto este ángulo que no conozco y que
le voy a llamar x y de este lado 1 que
es 90
usted como podemos encontrar este ángulo
x bueno sabemos que la suma de los
ángulos interiores de un triángulo debe
de ser igual a 180 grados vamos a sumar
esto tenemos nuestro ángulo recto que es
de 90 grados más está x más este ángulo
de 90 menos teta todo esto debe ser
igual a 180 grados bueno vamos a restar
180 en ambos lados este se va 90 más 90
180 menos 180 que estamos restando de
este lado se queda en 0 estos se van y
nos queda que x menos theta es igual a 0
o lo que es lo mismo que x es igual a
tec este ángulo de aquí es igual a theta
por lo tanto ese de aquí también lo es
bueno que más sabemos sabemos que este
borde de acá por encima del agua mide 72
metros y que todo el borde mide 180 así
que el borde que se encuentra por d
o la parte del borde que se encuentra
por debajo del agua mide 180 m 72
108 metros para qué nos sirve esto pues
nos va a servir para encontrar nuestra
altura h sabemos que este es un ángulo
recto
de 90 grados así que todo esto de aquí
es un triángulo rectángulo voy a
resaltarlo un poco para que se note este
es el triángulo más o menos si vemos
este triángulo y queremos encontrar h
vamos a tener que usar una función
trigonométricas para encontrar este lado
ya que tenemos un ángulo este ángulo
theta que funciona en econométrica
tenemos que usar con base en este ángulo
bueno vamos a recordar nuestro armónico
zocato a su caja oa qué elementos de
este tiempo lo vamos a usar tenemos el
ángulo conocemos este lado de acá que
mide 108 metros y queremos conocer la
altura entonces tenemos con respecto a
este ángulo la hipotenusa y el lado
adyacente seno es el lado opuesto entre
la hipotenusa no nos sirve el coseno ese
lado adyacente entre la hipotenusa este
si no sirve aquí si tenemos los dos
elementos la hipotenusa y el lado
opuesto así que el coseno con respecto a
este ángulo
el consell o de teta es igual al lado
adyacente que es h le pongo aquí h entre
la hipotenusa que mide 108
y esto ahorita no nos sirve mucho porque
todavía no conocemos cuál es el coche no
detecta pero tenemos una pista en esta
parte superior de la pirámide tenemos el
mismo ángulo theta así que quizás
podemos encontrar el coseno dt está
usando este triángulo más grande viendo
este triángulo más grande cuál es el
coste no de teta voy a resaltar este
triángulo grande con otro color
este es el triángulo que ahora vamos a
analizar para encontrar el coseno dt
está nuevamente el cose no detecta es el
lado adyacente entre la hipotenusa así
que el coche no detecta usando este
ángulo grandote es el seno de teta igual
a la da diaz ente 139 entre la
hipotenusa que quedamos que mide 180 108
más 72 180 y ahora tenemos estos cosenos
del mismo ángulo con estos valores esos
ángulos s tt de aquí y este de acá son
los mismos así que estos cosenos son
iguales por lo que
puedo escribir que h entre 108 es igual
a 139 entre 180 y sólo me resta despejar
h multiplico 108 en ambos lados de esta
igualdad y me queda que h es igual a 139
por 108 entre 180 y ahora sólo me resta
sacar mi calculadora para hacer estas
cuentas escribimos 139 por 108 igual y
esto lo dividimos entre 180
nos queda 83.4 así que la altura del
agua es igual a 83.4 metros